- [Voiceover] Two blocks are connected by
a string of negligible mass that passes
over massless pulleys that turn with
negligible friction, as shown in
the figure above, we see that there.
The mass m2 of block 2 is greater
than the mass m1 of block 1.
The blocks are released from rest.
So let's just really quick think about
what we think is going to happen here.
Block 2 has a larger
mass, they're connected
by this string and pulley system here.
Well if it has a larger
mass, they're in the
same gravitational
field, it's going to have
a larger weight and so the weight
pulling down on block 2 is going to be
larger than the weight
pulling down on block 1
and so you're going to have block 2
accelerating downwards, you're going
to have block 2 accelerating downwards
and block 1 is going to accelerate upwards
with the same magnitude.
So block 1 is going to accelerate upwards
and so with that just intuition
of what we think is going to happen here
let's try to tackle part A of this.
So they tell us the
dots below, these dots,
represent the two blocks, so this
represents block 1,
this represents block 2.
Draw free-body diagrams
showing and labeling
the forces, not components,
exerted on each block.
Draw the relative lengths of all vectors
to reflect the relative
magnitudes of all forces.
Alright, so let's think about what are
all the forces acting
on each of these blocks.
Well for each of these blocks you're going
to have the force of gravity, you're going
to have the weight of the
blocks acting on them,
so for example this first block m1,
m1, and I'll draw it here first,
what is the force of gravity going to be?
The force of gravity is going to be
its mass times the gravitational field.
Now what is going to be the
force of gravity on block 2?
Well it's going to be larger than that
so let me just draw it like this,
so the force of gravity is going to be
m2 times g, how did I know
it was going to be larger?
Well m2 has a larger mass and we are
in the same gravitational field.
Now we're not done there, no not done yet
because now we also have the upward
pulling force of the tension in the string
and we could think
about what the magnitude
of that, we know that the, we know that
the tension is going to be pulling upwards
on both of the blocks
but let's think about
what its magnitude is going to be.
In order for block 1
to accelerate upwards,
which is in our intuition
as to what would happen,
the tension, the force of the tension
has to be larger, the
magnitude of the tension
has to be larger than the
magnitude of the weight.
Now in order for block 2
to accelerate downwards
the magnitude of the
tension has to be less than
the downward force of gravity, the upward
force of tension has to be less than
the downward force of gravity.
So the magnitude of the tension
is going to be inbetween the magnitudes
of these two weights, so let me draw that.
So the magnitude of the
tension is going to be
larger than m1g but smaller than m2g,
so maybe like that, so
that is tension right there
and, whoops, and you're going to have
on this side you're going to have the same
magnitude of your tension pulling upwards
but it's now less than the weight,
which means that the block is
going to accelerate downwards
and we know that these two tensions,
the magnitudes of these tension vectors
are going to be the same because of
the magnitude of the tension throughout
this entire string is
going to be the same.
When you think about
tension, this pulling force,
you can think about what's happening at an
atomic or a molecular level
is these are the, you know
the covalent bonds pulling on each other
at an atomic level
throughout the entire string
and when we look at it on a macro level
we view that as tension.
So there you have it, I've drawn
the forces on them but I haven't
drawn them in the right place,
I need to draw them on this,
I need to draw them right over here.
So let me draw that, I can actually
draw a little bit more precisely
because they gave us these lines.
So on block 1 I have the weight
so that is m1g,
I also have the tension,
I'll make that two of these lines tall,
so I also have the tension.
Now block 2 I have the same tension
or same magnitude of tension I should say,
now it's also pulling upwards, so tension,
and I have its weight, which is going
to be larger than the tension,
so its weight, I'll make
it three of these lines.
The way I've drawn it m2 would have
to be three times, m2 would have to be
three times larger than
m1 the way I've drawn it.
They don't tell us that, they
tell us that m2 is larger
so this seems to be right.
And we just want to get our intuition here
since our tension, our upward force
is larger than our downward force
you're going to have a net upward force,
which is going to accelerate block 1 up
and here you're going to
have a net downward force,
which is going to accelerate block 2 down,
which is in line with our intuition
because block 2 weighs more than block 1.